c'est qu'on a été très sérieux donc
maintenant on va vous faire c'est
terrible c'est ici je suis vraiment
embêté que ça tombe sur vous mais bon en
même temps si l'interview nul en les
bouches pendant la guerre
bien vous préférez hitler ou staline ni
l'un ni l'autre à faut choisir camara
bit rich elle bien emmerdé
c'est impossible de répondre à une
question il ya quelques années un
communiste aurait pour du style oui les
temps changent quand même de times they
are a-changin' comme disait bob dylan
ouest alerte
ouais alors vous devez partir de 3 ans
dans un vaisseau spatial fameux vaisseau
spatial une tête très abîmée depuis le
temps vous préféré partir avec alain
duhamel
arlette chabot a je sais où jean pierre
elkabbach
après ça je sais c'est terrible
choisissez le moins pire ouais je prends
de la femme arlette chabot par les
tchèques à faire vous préférez un
président de la république d'extrême
droite élu au suffrage universel ou
annuler le processus démocratique
annuler le processus démocratique s'est
passé en algérie
vous préférez annuler le processus des
jeux pas fier à nu j'ai presque un
moment aussi en présence d'un public
d'extrême droite rim chant annaïck donc
j'ai pas démocrate pas démocratique
on est on peut pas démocrate jusqu'au
bout ah oui d'accord pas de liberté pour
les ennemis de la liberté quoi un peu
ouais ouais vous n'êtes pas complètement
changé encore non mais ça viendra
peut-être mais sur cette question là
j'ai même pas changé oui vous aimeriez
avoir un nez supplémentaires un doigt
supplémentaire ou un sexe
supplémentaires un lien supplémentaire
ça me servirait à rien un truc
supplémentaire qu'on peut compliquer
heures aura une voie supplémentaire doit
par que vous avoir oui exactement
regardant avec 2,6 en plus oui oui je
sais que vous pourriez avoir un sexe
deux filles
non je le dois d'avoir un sexe deux fils
non non non non c'est dur à gérer
oui c'est dur à gérer vous savez ça
mais vous n'aurez plus besoin de
l'alsacien à ce moment là albert nous
cette histoire d'alsaciens matin mais si
on a deux sexes d'avoir un doigt je suis
plus aux normes et à mener sur
l'ambiance livre patron de marianne
à votre avis quel est le sport le plus
con j'ai pas bien un sport que j'aime
pas parce que le curling
j'allais le dire bravo ça c'est vrai
c'est ça oui c'est celui que je vais
vous citer mais le curling c'est qu'on
le coeur il ya un mec qui balaie tu
devrais il ya un mec qui balaient devant
un truc là on vous c'est quoi le sport
le plus con pour vous le cricket parce
qu'il est compliqué ouais vous vois le
mec qui se fait chier à chelsea si vous
étiez en vente dans un sex shop vous
seriez quoi si j'étais en vendant
sexuelle je serai quoi il faudra latex
non non une cassette vidéo
ouais ouais c'est bien il faut dans le
texte pourquoi wagne jeu rouge vous vous
laver les cheveux tous les combien tous
les jours tous les jours alors imaginez
vous deviez partir sur l'île déserte
oui quand je le laisserais bien sûr vous
partiriez avec une free l'esprit vous
partiriez avec une fille très moche ou
un mec très beau
non je vais vous décevoir non avec un
maître bau donc vous êtes un peu non
mais je préfère le bout ah ouais mais
qu'est ce que vous feriez sur cette île
je voulais deux manières il s'en produit
l'état il est pas complètement fermé ou
truc quand même browser par terry avec
quoi je viendrai - en moi moi je suis en
tout cas on a tous les trois ans - moi
je vous dis une semaine un mec très beau
merci à qui attribuez vous le plus de
circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles jeunes
qui tapent sur des vieilles c'est vrai
il ya au moins de quelques puisque
raison de le faire a admis en même temps
c'est courant mais ça ni pour pesko dans
le viiième braqueurs dans le 8ème c'est
plutôt les vieux qui se tape des petites
quand je suis sidéré par cette réponse
j'aime le fait qu'ils partent avec un
mélange brésil et plus naturelle si
j'ose dire c'est peut-être critiquable
mais c'est si je suis plus naturel que
quand on est un jeune de taper sur les
vieilles en moi je trouve ça plus
naturel imaginez que vous vous
réincarner en slip
vous préféreriez être le slip de
françois hollande
j'essaie c'est dur de laurent fabius en
dehors du parti socialiste vous n'avez
pas d'autres chronos à la suite de qui
patridge je vais essayer de faire en
sorte de papa c'est au cip et puis
j'irai en rythme annuel c'est normal
c'est celui qui est le plus proche de
vos idées ne s'était pas exhaustive
oui il vaut mieux aussi l'interview nul
il vaut mieux être riche et qu'on ou
intelligent et pour
pour intelligent et pauvres intelligent
et pauvres ouais d'accord avec ça va
sinon on est intelligent et riche et pas
mal non plus oui je fais mieux ça c'est
une question qu'il est arrivé par e-mail
de jean-philippe de liège encore un
belge
ouais ouais et vous préfériez quoi alors
est riche et quant aux intelligents et
pauvres je sais qu'on